Hallo, guten Tag, mein Name ist Kapagann, ich bin hier als Dienstabendarzt tätig und
würde gerne mit Ihnen das an einem Lesen gesprach führen. Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne mir Bescheid sagen.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Bescheidensprache möchte ich ganz schnell eine Frage an Sie stellen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja genau, schon guten Tag.
Danke, wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Yildiz Karahan.
Yildiz Karahan. Okay, Frau Karahan, wie alt sind Sie? 35 Jahre alt.
Frau Karahan, wie alt sind Sie? 1985.
87? Genau, ja.
Wie viel wiegen Sie Frau Karahan? 80 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie? 1,60.
Frau Karahan, was führt Sie zu uns? Was für Beschwerde haben Sie momentan?
Ich habe gestern eine starke Bauchschmerzen und sie kommt ab und zu und eine stichende Schmerzen.
Manchmal so duft, aber stichende.
Ich habe auch übergelegt, dass sie noch erbrechen. Ich habe gedacht, dass sie nachlassen, aber es scheint, dass es nicht besser wird.
Ja, okay, verstehe. Das ist gut, dass Sie hierher gekommen sind. Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe nicht eine starke Bauchschmerzen, aber dann ging es wieder besser.
Sie waren nicht bei anderen Arzt, wegen der Beschwerden?
Ja, ich war damals bei meinen anderen Arzt.
Sie haben kurzfristig eine Weataka gekommen, bei Frauen gibt es auch eine Bauchschmerz.
Man kann keine Schmerzen bekommen, aber es scheint nicht so zu sein.
Okay, genau. Haben Sie diese Stichende und du verschmerzen?
Sind diese Schmerzen Plösti aufgetreten?
Ja, ich muss sagen, ja, es ist wie blödlich eigentlich. Es ist schwierig zu differenzieren.
Gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nein, ich lebe die Leid von den Jahren.
Ich bleibe schon.
Ich möchte Schmerzmittel einnehmen, sonst geht nicht weg.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit verändert?
Haben Sie sich die Schmerzen verschlechtert oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Ich muss etwas einnehmen, ich könnte das nicht durchhalten.
Ich muss etwas einnehmen, sonst heule ich.
Ich könnte das nicht durchhalten.
Ich würde das nicht aushalten.
Strahlen die Schmerzen in andere bestimmte Körperteile aus?
Ja, ich habe die Schmerzen-Attacke bekommen, am meisten zieht sich nach rücken.
Im dem Zeitpunkt kann ich mich nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Aber auch wahrscheinlich.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie starke Bauchschmerzen sind.
Wo gerne sind die Schmerzen?
Ich muss fragen.
Oberbauch oder rechtsseitige Bauch oder linksseitige Bauch?
Das ist eher so eine Oberbauch.
Aber danach ist das gesamte Bauch.
Er hat einen Start- und Überbauch.
Hallo?
Ich konnte nichts zuhören, mein Internet ist ein bisschen weggegangen.
Können Sie wiederholen?
Sie haben gesagt, Oberbauchschmerzen haben Sie?
Ja, am Anfang ist das der Oberbauch, um den gesamten Bauch zu sagen.
Sie haben wieder Internetprobleme, jetzt ganz weg.
Ja, jetzt ist es gekommen.
Können Sie wiederholen?
Es ist ein sehr überbauchbereich, um den gesamten Bauch zu sagen.
Okay, gesamten Bauch.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei ein sehr leichter und sehr starker Schmerz meint?
Ich würde sagen, 10.
Okay, das ist starker Schmerz.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich freue mich, wenn ich gar nichts sehe.
Haben Sie etwas eingenommen, um diese Schmerzen zu linden?
Sie haben gesagt, vorher hatten Sie eingenommen.
Aber seit gestern haben Sie etwas eingenommen?
Ich nehme immer dauerhaft ein Epiphofen.
Aber trotzdem habe ich Schmerzen.
Das ist nicht, dass ich schmerzfrei bin.
Ich nehme so eine 600 Milliklampern Epiphofen.
Aber trotzdem ist es immer noch nicht ganz, dass ich sage,
dass ich schmerzfrei bin.
Ich habe immer noch Schmerzen.
Okay.
Und gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für diese Schmerzen?
Ja, und noch eine Frage.
Sind die Schmerzen nauresabhängig oder bewegungsabhängig?
Gute Frage.
Ich habe das nicht geachtet, aber ich gehe davon aus,
dass die Baugestellenauslöse war nach dem Essen.
Fettiges Essen oder?
Ich esse immer so fettiges, muss man sagen.
Das ist nicht das, was ich gestern besonders war.
Okay.
Und wir können sagen, deshalb ist das eine nauresabhängig.
Als ich gesagt habe, gestern fangen wir nach dem Essen an.
Nach dem Essen, ja.
Und danach habe ich jetzt keine Lust, was zu essen, ja.
Okay, genau.
Jetzt verstehe ich.
Ist die nun übel?
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, übel freit haben sie erbrochen und hau...
Wie viele Mal haben sie erbrochen?
So zweimal.
Zweimal, seit gestern, ja.
Mhm.
Wie sieht das erbrochen aus?
Zuerst ein bisschen garlig.
Garlig, okay.
Ist die nicht schwindelig?
Nee.
Haben sie es nicht zugehört?
Sie haben wieder Verbindung, Probleme wahrscheinlich.
Frage war...
Meine letzte Frage war...
Wie sieht das aus?
Wie sieht das erbrochen aus?
Garlig haben sie und...
Schwindel haben sie.
Schwindel, genau.
Ist die schwindel?
Schwindel, nee.
Ich habe keine Schwindel.
Okay, keine Schwindel.
Haben sie Fieber?
Mir war ein bisschen warm.
Die hat es nicht gemessen, aber wahrscheinlich das war Fieber.
Ich probiere jetzt auch mal eine Kamera.
Weiter.
Ist die nicht schwindelig?
Sie haben gerade einen?
Haben sie Fieber?
Als die gestern war, war es dann auch wahrscheinlich das war Fieber.
Ich kann das nicht mehr sehen.
Ich habe keine Gracias da raus.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Nachschweiß oder Schüttelfrost?
Gestern war, ich habe richtig Schüttelfrost bekommen,
Nachschweiß noch dazu.
Das war auch ein Schmerzener Tanker, ja.
Das war nicht, dass ich spontan bekommen habe,
Das ist auch normal, wenn man Schmerzen hat, dann trieb man das auch hoch wahrscheinlich.
Ich gehe davon aus.
So stark Schmerzen habe ich nie im Leben gehabt.
Ja, ja.
Das ist nicht so zu beigetragen, ja.
Genau, ich glaube bei Ihnen, ja.
Nach Schweiß haben Sie auch, genau.
Einmal gestern Abend.
Einmal gestern, genau, ja.
Wie ist die Abwehrtät?
Ich glaube, kein Lust jetzt.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ungebot ab oder zu genommen?
Ne, ich habe ab noch so genommen.
Ab oder, ist nicht verändert, ihr Gewicht.
Gewicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Sturrgang?
Ne, habe ich auch kein Problem.
Das ist gut.
Oder Schmerzen oder brennende Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen oder beim Sturrgang?
Aber leiden Sie unter Völlegefühl oder Beleihung oder saures Aufstoßen?
Seit gestern habe ich das natürlich normal.
So ein Aufstoß habe ich.
Aber seit gestern.
Ja, seit gestern.
Und Sortbrennen?
Leiden Sie unter Sortbrennen?
Stark würde ich nicht sagen, weil ich es einmal erbrochen habe.
Es brennt schon.
Und wenn es durch den Maserbeiß oder durch den Erbrechen ist,
kann ich nicht unterscheiden.
Ja, okay.
Frau Karahan, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie eine bestimmte Vorerkampfung von denen ich wissen sollte,
z.B. Bluthochdruck oder Blutzverkrankheit?
Oder Schilddreselne über Funktion?
Ich war kein gesund, auch bisher.
Ich habe nie etwas eingenommen.
Nein, habe ich gar keine.
Keine Vorerkampfung haben Sie?
Okay, das ist gut.
Aber müssen wir natürlich noch einmal kontrollieren.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamentein außer diese Ibuprofen?
Ibuprofen nehme ich auch nicht regelmäßig.
Das ist nur, weil ich Schmelzen hatte.
Aber immer noch so einen Abgrund zu machen,
man kriegt so eine Bauchschmelze,
man kann nicht so einen Rücken schmelzen.
Aber es ist nicht, dass ich dauerhaft einnehmen muss.
Aber sonst nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ein.
Nein.
Regelmäßig nehmen Sie nichts ein.
Genau, aber manchmal bei Bedarf, diese Ibuprofen nehmen Sie ein.
Genau.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein.
Okay.
Frau Karahan, sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Auflich bekannt.
Das ist schönes Kind.
Sind bei Ihnen Untertätigkeiten bekannt?
Was noch bekannt?
Untertätigkeit.
Es ist auch nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Raufen Sie?
Ja.
Wie viel Raufen Sie?
10 Stück pro Tag seit 10 Jahren.
10 Jahren.
Raufen Sie Zigarette?
Ja, genau.
Was geben Sie?
Rücken wir Alkohol?
Nein.
Bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine medizinische Frage.
Ich möchte die Frage noch die Drogen nehmen.
Nein, habe ich nie probiert.
Auch nicht genommen.
Das ist schon.
Frau Karahan, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin dreimal geimpft.
Für die vierte habe ich auch Termine ausgemacht.
Für was?
Für die vierte Impfung.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Ich weine den Türkei vor ein paar Monaten.
Vor ein paar Monaten.
Ich meine die tropischen Regionen.
Afrika.
Sie treiben die Sport?
Ich bin davon sehr voll.
Sie können nicht Sport treiben.
Ich kann, aber ich bin sehr voll.
Ich muss mich ein bisschen motivieren und anstrengen.
Ich mache jetzt natürlich so einen Jogging.
Aber nicht regelmäßig.
Ja, okay.
Sport wäre gut für Ihre
gesundheitszustand.
Deshalb empfehle ich Ihnen,
Sport zu treiben.
Weil ich Obergewicht bin, meinst du, oder?
Nein, für jede Menschen ist das.
Ja, gut.
Lebensweise.
Dankeschön.
Darf ich fragen, wie ist die Familienerkrankungen?
Ich habe mich auch sehr gefühlt.
Ich habe regelmäßig ein Problem damit.
Manchmal Versögerung,
durch Striss und so weiter.
Ich nehme das an.
Ich gehe auch so regelmäßig zu meiner Frauenarzt.
Ich habe mich auch sehr gefühlt.
Frauenarzt.
Das habe ich gar kein Problem gehabt.
Frau Krann, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Leider konnte ich nicht gut hören.
Ich habe gesagt, ja.
Das sind wieder Probleme.
Mein Internet, ich weiß es nicht, warum ist das?
Hören Sie mich hier?
Ja, ja, jetzt höre ich, genau, jetzt kann ich gut hören.
Antwort zu Ihrer Frage, ja.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei.
Okay, Söhne oder Tochter?
Ein Tochter.
Okay.
Und sind beide gesund?
Ja, die sind beide gesund, erzählt.
Gut, also schon.
Mit wem wollen Sie zusammen?
Mit meinem Mann.
Mann und mit Tochter, ja, oder?
Ja, mit Kindern, wir sind alle zusammen.
Alle zusammen, okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, habe ich keine.
Keine Geschwister.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter eigentlich, ich lebe noch.
Mein Vater ist noch vor zehn Jahren verstorben.
Woran ist er gestorben?
Das tut mir leid, das ist...
Ja, der war jung, hat so eine Herzprobleme.
Und ob er sich das eine Herzstelle-Strand-Geschichte
des ummächtigen Tod in der Wohnung gefunden.
Okay, ist das Herzimpfung oder so?
Auch wahrscheinlich, ich dir kenne das nicht herausfinden.
Wir wollten auch keine Obduktion mehr haben.
Aber am Ende haben wir gesagt, er ist tot und auch wahrscheinlich.
Der hatte auch mit dem Herz, was schon gehabt,
sondern zwei oder drei Mal so eine Herzprobleme gehabt.
Aber ich weiß auch nicht genau.
Okay, ja, alles klar.
Hat die Mutter wichtige Erkrankungen?
Nein, das habe ich auch nicht gemacht.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte,
z.B. Leberkrankheit oder Blutzuckerkrankheit,
Bluthochdruck in der Familie Großeltern?
Mein Vater hatte eine Herzprobleme.
Das war auch Hochblutdruck noch dazu.
Der hatte auch Probleme mit dem Gefäße.
Ich könnte auch nicht genau wissen, was das war.
Aber der war oft über den Gefäßespezialisten
und bei Herzspazialisten.
Die kenne ich aber mehr, weiß ich nicht genau.
Ob meine Unkel etwas hatte oder meine Tante,
die weiß ich nicht genau.
Was machen Sie aus beruflich?
Ich bin Hausfrau.
Sie sind zufrieden oder haben Sie Stress?
Ja, wenn man zu Hause ist, hat man immer Stress.
Welche Frau hat keine Stress zu Hause?
Man soll manchmal ablenken.
Das bringen Sie immer.
Aber können Sie damit umgehen?
Ich habe keine andere Wahl.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, ich schlafe sehr gut.
Ich habe wieder mit euch schlafen.
Ich habe wieder mit euch schlafen oder mit Einschlafen Probleme.
Okay, genau.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Karahan, von meiner Seite habe ich viele Fragen an Sie gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, Sie haben einen Schlag Schmerz.
Sie haben nie gefragt, ob Sie Schmerzen haben?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Ich werde Sie ganz schnell körperlich untersuchen.
Danach werde ich Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel geben,
damit Sie gut ausschalten können.
Dann werden wir Sie bei Ihnen ein paar Blutuntersuchungen durchführen.
Auch ein Baukulturalschall bei Ihnen durchführen.
Dann mit diesem Ergebnis und mit diesem Informationen
werde ich mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Nachdem ich nach der Nachricht von der Frau Karahan
zurückgekommen und zu Ihnen etwas tun.
Zuerst müssen Sie bei uns bleiben für weitere Untersuchungen
und Behandlungen.
Aber ganz schnell werden Sie ein Schmerzmittel bekommen.
Danke schön.
Was steht mir noch vor?
Das heißt nach dem Rücksprachen mit Oberarzt,
wenn Sie Ihre Entscheidung treffen,
was geplant wird bei mir?
Ganz genau.
Das ist eine Galenbilanzzündung bei Ihnen.
Noch eine Frage möchte ich stellen.
Leiden Sie unter Yukreis?
Keine Yukreis.
Haben unsere Kollegen eine Frage?
Ich möchte etwas biegen.
Kommentar zum Beispiel.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Gelb sucht.
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn eine Frage?
Nein, ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn Ihre Bauchschmerzen einmal Stuhlgang oder Gehenwind ab?
Nein, ich habe es starker Bauchschmerzen, aber ich war nie auf der Rente.
Okay.
Welche Hautfarbung,
helle oder türkische Frau,
aber für die
französischen Diagnose habe ich
die Musik fragen.
Die Musik fragen.
Über Bauchschmerzen und Tüpfelschmerzen
und eine Diagnose
und 6F
und eine Depositas
weiblich geschlecht und heller Haut gibt.
Ich muss fragen,
oder...
Genau, ja, muss man fragen, heller Haut oder
das können Sie aber selbst sehen.
Man fragt nicht,
wer Hautfarbe haben Sie, Sie sehen es doch.
Ja, ich muss sehen, aber...
Muss ich dritt dokumentieren oder notieren, zu sagen.
Okay.
Was Sie sehen können, das brauchen Sie nicht zu fragen.
Was Sie nicht sehen, natürlich, was Sie wissen wollen.
Es geht um eine Änderung, ob eine Hautfarbe Änderung ist
oder was, das können Sie gerne fragen.
Ja, dass Sie sich die Haut oder Augen in der Zeit...
Ja, genau, das ist wichtig. Wenn Sie so fragen,
wer Hautfarbe haben Sie, dann man fragt,
dann was fragt er, was geht, ich habe doch...
meine Haut steht vor Ihnen, Sie können es genau anschauen.
Herr Le Stuhl, habt ihr die Bemerkungen?
Habt ihr Herr Le Stuhl?
Gerade gefragt worden, ich habe seit gestern keine Stuhlgange.
Ja, ich habe diese...
wurde diese Fragen gestärkt, ich konnte nicht hören,
es wurde auch gefragt, nee.
Ne, okay, das ist das.
Haben Sie eine andere Frage?
Ich glaube, eine wichtige Frage wurde vergessen,
eine sehr, sehr wichtige.
Welche Frage?
Da gibt es in Europa bestimmt eine Chirurgie,
eine chirurgische Frage, oder?
Haben wir, wenn jemand da ist, dann soll er sagen,
gibt es eine Strahlung, ich möchte es.
Das wurde auch gefragt.
Ja, ich habe das.
Ich habe gestern einen Mittag.
Was habe ich gegessen?
Was habe ich gegessen, ein fettreiches, muss man sagen,
das war ein schönes Fleisch,
mit Kartoffeln und Gemüse und noch Reis dazu.
Aber sehr lecker.
Ein sehr leckeres Restaurant, oder?
Ich habe das zu Hause selbst gekocht.
Was ist die Frage, Herr Hüijan?
Was war die wichtige Frage?
Schmeißen Überbauch, genau, wo überbauch, recht, links?
Ja, das habe ich gefragt.
Aber gefragt hat er...
Ja, Sie haben gefragt, wo haben Sie überbaucht,
dann haben Sie...
dann war nichts mehr, dann kam gar nichts mehr,
dann gab es einen recht überbauch,
links überbauch, der Mitte überbauch,
das war Sie nicht gefragt.
Nein, gefragt, wo die Schmeißen am steigsten sind.
Ja, Oberbauch habe ich gesagt.
Reicht überbauch, recht überbauch,
ob und mittel...
Reicht habe ich nicht gehört.
Wo genau die Schmeißen sind, habe ich das verstanden,
habe ich gesagt, ob überbauch.
Ja, rechtsseitige Bauch und linksseitige Oberbauch
habe ich auch gefragt.
Aber vielleicht, dann habe ich das tut mir leid,
dann verschein ich mich.
Ja, das war alles gut, ja.
Und was haben wir noch...
nix vergessen,
also strandeschmeißend in der Schulter...
Rücken.
Rücken, glaube ich,
zwischen bei der Schulter, er rechts,
okay, das ist auch gefragt worden.
Sonst haben wir alles gefragt, sehr gut, okay.
Dann...
Das wird auch gefragt, eigentlich.
Aber...
Stichende Schmeißen habe ich gesagt.
Ja, Stichende Schmeißen.
Aber...
Patient hat gesagt,
am steigsten Oberbauch,
aber...
Später, im Verlauf habe ich den gesamten Bauchbereich, ja.
Und das war nicht erstmalig,
aber nicht in diesem Art, ja, erstmalig,
aber ich habe so ein Beschwem,
vor zwei, drei Monaten,
zwei Monate habe ich gesagt, ja, so ungefähr.
Drei Monate.
Ja, drei Monate, genau.
Ich habe es dann,
ich habe es dann beschweden gehabt,
dann habe ich es dann immer pro Fin genommen,
dann war wieder weg.
So war die Antwort.
Die Patient hat gesagt,
Schmeiß attacken.
Und sehr hausam,
Wir mussten fragen,
wie lange dauert der Tag?
Wie lange dauert der Tag?
Schmeiß attacken.
Als ich sagen kann,
ich nehme sofort eine Schmerzmittel,
bis das weckt,
ungefähr so eine halbe Stunde bis eine Stunde dauert das.
Aber ich kann es nicht aushalten,
deswegen muss ich etwas einnehmen.
Ich weiß nicht genau,
wenn ich gar nichts einnehme,
wie lange das noch dauern könnte,
das kann ich mich nicht vorstellen.
Das könnte schon noch länger dauern.
Ich habe Fragen.
Diese Schmerzintensität ist zähn.
Sehr stark Schmerzen.
Und die Patient,
die Schmerzmittel,
die ich mir in diesem Stadion habe,
müssen wir schnell überprüfen.
Schmerzen und andere Werte
müssen wir sehen.
Meine Vorschlage,
wenn Sie so eine Patientinur aufgenommen haben,
Sie müssen die Schmerzen sofort lokalisieren lassen,
die es messen.
Wenn Sie das notiert haben,
dann braucht es nicht auf etwas anderes zu warten.
Sie sollen den Patient sofort Schmerzmittel geben,
parallel können Sie doch Blut,
Labo abnehmen,
parallel andere Diagnostikverfahren durchführen.
Mit Schmerzen können Sie auch nicht weiter Diagnostik machen.
Ich nehme das CT durchführen.
Ich habe das CT durchführen.
Wie können Sie eine Patientin mit Schmerzskala
von 10 in das CT reinbringen?
Der wird sich nicht stil halten,
der wird heulet.
Der Argument,
bis zum Diagnostikbeschluss
oder bis zum Diagnostikentschluss
soll man gar nichts geben,
das finde ich nicht okay.
Vor allem gab es in der Türkei
eine Standardverfahren,
die Diagnostik durchführen.
Es gibt dann erst nachts etwas gegen Schmerzen.
Wir haben alle Mittel,
um die Probleme nachvollziehen
und zu beweisen.
Sie haben auch CT-Möglichkeiten,
im Ultraschall vorhanden.
Manchmal ist es so,
bis Sie das haben,
dann legen Sie sich die Schicht zu 3 Stunden
und dann sollen Sie durchhalten.
Ich würde so empfehlen,
sofort Körper untersuchen.
Die Rest der anderen Anämnese,
die müssen auch durchführen,
die Familie, die Gewöhnlichkeit,
die hat stark Schmerzen,
erst mal sich auf die Probleme konzentrieren.
Auf den akuten Ereignissen,
wo es der Bauchschmerzen ist,
wie lange, wie und wo ist die Lokalisation,
was ist der Auslöser,
wenn Sie das analysiert haben,
dann wird der akute Sache analysiert.
Dann machen wir eine Grundgeschichte hinterher.
Das wird auch verlangen in der Prüfung.
Meines Erachtens,
auch vor allem in den Praktisch-Leben,
wenn Sie hier in der Notaufnahme sind,
Sie können nicht den Patienten sagen, Sie können durchhalten.
Können wir erst das Gespräch anfangen?
Genau, können wir machen.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Herr Oberarst, hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ja, gerne.
Frau Yildiz Karahan ist 39 Jahre alt
und 80 Kilogramm schwer
und 1,6 cm.
Frau Yildiz Karahan
hat sich heute bei uns,
wegen starker Oberbauchschmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen seien stehend und dumpf
und persistieren.
Als Begleit-Person
neben dieser Schmerzen
hatte der Patient
Übelkeit und Erbriefen gehabt.
Seit gestern
habe sie zwei Mal erbrochen.
Sie haben gar nicht mehr mitgekommen.
Sie haben sich heute
mitgekommen.
Sie haben gar nicht mehr ausgesehen.
Vor drei Monaten
hatte der Patient ähnliche Beschwerden.
Sie haben die Patienten
Schmerzmittel genommen.
Dann ist die Schmerzen wieder weggegangen.
Sie sind wieder weggegangen.
Gestern
war die Schmerz seitdem
am Oberbauch.
Dann
in den Rücken
ausstrahlen.
Sie hätten in den Rücken ausgestrahlt.
Sie schmerzen in den Rücken.
Sie können es auch sagen.
Genau, strahlten in den Rücken.
Die Patienten können nicht
diese Schmerzen aushalten.
Die Patienten haben
600 mg Übelkaufentaggänge
eingenehm.
Aber das haben sie
keine Linderung gebracht.
Die Schmerzen sind nach dem Fettiges Essen
aufgetreten.
Die Patienten
sind wieder weggegangen.
Sie haben die Patienten
neben der Übelkeit erbriefen.
Sie haben Fieber, Schüttelfrost,
Nachschweiß, Inapetens,
Saueresaufstoßen
und Pyrosis.
Sie haben ein Leiter in Sonja.
Sie haben keine Vorrechnung.
Die Patienten nehmen keine
Medikamente ein.
Die Patienten sind nicht
operiert worden.
Sie werden verneint.
Bei dieser Patientin
keine Allergie bekannt.
Und keine Allergie und
die Patienten rauchen seit 10 Jahren
10 Stück Zigarette pro Tag.
Das heißt 5 Packung Jars
und Alkoholkonsum
und Drogenkonsum.
Die Patienten sind vollständig geübt
und die Reise in der letzten Zeit im Ausland
sei unaufgängig.
Die Patienten treiben
Sport.
Die Frauen an einem Lese
sei unaufgängig.
Die Patienten sind verheiratet.
Ich habe einen Sohn,
eine Tochter, die beide gesund sind.
Die Patienten wohnen
mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Ich habe eine Erkrankung
mit der Patientin.
Der Vater der Patientin
sei vor 10 Jahren an einer Herzerkrankung gestorben.
Vorher habe er
Arthriore Hypertoni und Gefäßeerkrankungen.
Die Mutter der Patientin
sei gesund und lebt noch.
Die Patientin sei Hausfrau
und hat seit gestern
in Sonja erwähnt.
Die Frage nach
Gelb sucht.
Die Patientin
hat hinzugefügt,
dass sie gestern
eine Fleischkartoffeln
und ein fettiges Essen
zu Hause gekocht und gegessen.
Nach diesem fettigen Essen
sind die Oberbauchschmerzen
aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzattacken
haben halbe Stunde gedauert.
Die anäquestrischen Angaben
deuten am ersten auf eine
kollektivische Erkrankung.
Die Anäqueste
haben mehr Erkrankungen.
Die Schmerzattacken
kommen am ersten auf eine
kollektivische Erkrankung.
Die Schmerzattacken
kommen am ersten auf eine
kollektivische Erkrankung.
Die Schmerzattacke
Morbus Crohn und Ulcus Ventriculi, Ulcus Duedoni,
diese kommen in Betrat und zur weiteren Abgelerung würde ich die Patientin
zuerst körperlich untersuchen und dann der Patientin Blut abnehmen
und eine Bauchultraschall würde ich durchführen
und EKG wird geschrieben und gegebenenfalls ein Bauch City würde ich eine City,
Abdomen City, veranlassen und ein für, wegen dieser internistischen Konsol würde ich
auch Antworten und wegen dieser Cholestitis geben,
fast ein chirurgisches Konsol, werde ich auch Antworten.
Prüßunterbrechung.
Sie erwähnen alles sehr gut, es ist ein sehr ausführliches Differenzial der Genosa,
aber Sie sind eine Notaufnahme, Sie haben den Patient gesehen
und sie leidet unter einer Burebauchbeschwerden.
Was würden Sie als erstes machen? Sie haben den Patientin gesehen, oder?
Genau, als erstes werde ich die Körperbeschwörter untersuchen,
dann gleichzeitig Zugang legen und Blut abnehmen und dann Schmerzmittel geben.
Sofort Schmerz wird dann natürlich Schöck untersucht,
leichter, guter Anämnis, Kreislaufkontrolle ist auch wichtig,
dass die Monitor, die die Patientin mal anschaut, Blutdruck, Puls, Sättigung,
mit Temperatur.
Und was würden Sie als nächstes machen? Sie haben ein Unterscheidgerät auch in der Notaufnahme.
Ob es eine Sonografie ist, würde ich schon.
Der Notaufnahme in Deutschland ist standard, egal ob sie chirurgisch sind oder internistisch,
egal welcher Fach einrichtet, spielt keine Rolle, Sie müssen das machen.
Sie machen einen Unterscheid, und das wird auch in der Prüfung gefragt,
dass sie das machen können oder dürfen.
Sie haben jetzt über Differenzialdiagnose so viele Erzählzungen genannt.
Wie ist mit einem Nierenkollekt? Könnte auch so ein Nierenkollekt sein?
Ja, könnte sein.
Das wäre eine rechte Oberbauchüberschwörende, das klingt nach Schulles des Titels,
so ein Nierenkollekt, von Quentitis könnte auch sein, aber Quentitis sieht nicht nach
Linkunterbauch, recht könnte auch so sein, aber sie sind richtig.
Die Differenzialdiagnose, was Sie erzählt haben, ist alles richtig.
Natürlich, die Diagnostikverfahren startet mit einem Unterscheid,
und danach Blutinnahme und was würden Sie als Nächstes machen?
Würden Sie das Patientin direkt chirurgisch oder internistisch vorstellen?
Einen Naruskollekt, wie werde ich empfehlen?
Nein, welche Fachreinrichtung würden Sie dann konsolärisch vorstellen?
Einen internistischen Konsolv, werde ich antworten.
Oder chirurgischer Konsolv.
Ach gut, habt du immer einen größeren Konsolv?
Ja, die Internisten können alles, viele es sehen, wie genau, wie Sie jetzt
1000 Sachen genannt haben, aber chirurgisch muss es genau fachlich einschätzen,
welche Akkutsprobleme im Vordergrund stehen können und was die machen sollen.
Ob der Akkuts CT-Abdomen durchführen müssen, das sollen die entscheiden.
Aber erst nach der Mutterscheid, wenn Sie geschallt haben und gesehen haben,
dass die Galernblase, die bei dick sind, insündet aussieht, oder Steinen in den Galernabgang,
dann ist es auch eine Diagnostikverfahren, das ist auch ausreichend manchmal.
Die brauchen nicht unbedingt CT-Abdomen, aber natürlich am meisten machen CT-Abdomen.
Die warten auch auf den Labo-Wetter.
Was würden Sie denn in Labo-Wetter achten?
Labo-Wetter und Pankraswerte und Galernblasenwerte würde ich auch überprüfen.
Nierenwerte und CRP wegen dieser Entzündung und Blutsängersgeschwindigkeit.
Und CRP-Blutsängern.
Ja, diese werden wir natürlich auch überprüfen.
Kleines Blutbild und dann der Rest haben Sie vollrecht.
Nämlich handelt die Lipaserwerte sind sehr hoch erhört. Was machen Sie denn?
Lipaserwerte, wenn sehr hoch erhört ist, werde ich eine Akute-Pankratitis verlauftdiagnose haben.
Und wegen dieser Akute-Pankratitis werde ich eine RSCP durchführen.
RSCP bei Akute-Pankratitis.
Wie bitte?
RSCP wollen Sie durchführen bei der Verdacht auf Akute-Pankratitis.
Genau, ja.
Das macht man nie.
Oder?
Nein.
Garne Steingänge und Umgang.
Umgekehrt, umgekehrt, ja, es ist etwas anders.
Wenn Sie eine Garne Steinabgang haben, wenn Sie eine Schulle-Docholiteasis haben,
eine Schulle-Systetisch-Baschulle-Docholiteasis und die dann voraussagt eine Pankratitis,
das ist etwas anders.
Dafür brauchen Sie eine MRCP, das ist mal MRCP heißt das.
Das ist eine spezielle MRT-Verfahren, die man die Garne-Gänge darstellen kann.
Wenn Sie dort eine Steine feststellen können, dann machen Sie eine RSCP,
weil die Auslöser für die Pankratitis auch diese Stein ist.
Nehm ich an, dass Sie die Steine nicht gesehen haben, Sie haben eine RSCP durchgeführt.
Auch klinisch passt nicht die Schulle-Docholiteasis, aber Sie haben die Parasiliter erhöht.
Okay.
Dann werde ich eine internistische Konsul antworten.
Das ist ganz klares Verfall zu sagen, eine Komplikation.
Sie haben eine kultusche Stistitis.
Das könnte erscheinen, dass ein Infekt regert, dass Pankratitis auch ja
eine Stressbedingung aufgetreten ist.
Daher brauchen Sie gar keine Diagnostik.
Sie geben etwas in den Physionen, aber parallel, wenn die Schulle-Docholiteasis
im Vordergrund kommt, dann sind sie im Programm seine OP.
Da gibt es keine Diskussion, wenn die Chiruroren das durchoperieren wollen.
Das ist etwas anders, das ist eine Chirurung-Höhn-Scheidung.
Das will ich mich nicht einmischen natürlich, weil das sollen die entscheiden,
ob die operieren wollen oder nicht.
Aber ich würde es an Chiruronsch trotzdem vorstellen.
Bei Pankratitis, wenn Sie nur reihenfolge Pankratitis haben,
ohne Schulle-Sistitis, ohne Schulle-Docholiteasis,
dann machen Sie gar keine ESP.
Eine Frage, ist eine ESP Kontraindikation bei dieser Graf?
Bei Pankratitis, weil die ESP selbst macht Pankratitis.
Die Komplikation für die ESP ist Pankratitis.
Wenn Sie nur eine Pankratitis haben, noch parallel eine ESP durchführen,
dann verdoppeln Sie die Komplikation, dann haben Sie noch mehr Probleme.
Weil die ESP bringt nichts.
Wenn Sie sagen, dass Pankratitis ist,
man versucht soweit, wie möglich sich von den interventionalen Verfahren
fernzuhalten, weil jede Verfahren dort in den Pankersgang
verschlemmert den Verlauf, als zu verbessern.
Daher man versucht, nicht ein invasives Verfahren,
zum Beispiel MRCP, da muss man sicher sein,
dass da ein Stein da ist, dann gehe ich da hin.
Nehm ich im Kauf, weil ich das gesehen habe.
Wenn ich das nicht gesehen habe, das mache ich gar nicht.
Dann sage ich, ich habe das ausgeschlossen,
ich habe keine Steine da gesehen, dann werde ich keine,
wenn ich verdachte eine Pankratitis habe, mache ich keine ESP.
Weil es in Kriegs- und Schmerzmetall-Infusion,
dann braucht man gar nichts.
Sogar keine Antibiotika, aber wenn man keine Inzündungwerte hat,
vor allem bei so einer jungen Frau, braucht man keine Antibiotika,
solange keine Inzündungzeichen hat.
Nur lokale Pankratitis kommt auch durch den Gewichtszunahmer,
durch den Stress, durch den Tausendeinanderer-Sache
auch verursacht sein.
Man weiß nicht, der raucht auch, braucht es auch
in den Faktoren von Pankratitis.
Man muss nicht unbedingt Alkohol trinken,
man sieht auch, dass es Pankratitis ist.
Eine Frage, wenn wir eine Pankratitis als Pardatierung haben
und können wir aber eine MRCP durchführen,
oder müssen wir?
Mussten Sie nicht, wenn Sie eine Pankratitis haben,
machen Sie eine CT.
MRCP, MRCP auch können.
Können Sie machen, wenn Sie eine Verdacht haben
im Sinne von eine Schul- und Durch-Litiasis.
Wenn Sie vermuten, dass die Pankratitis-Folge
von einer Schul- und Durch-Litiasis ist,
dass die Stein in den Schul- und Durch-Gegangen-List
den Weg zu ist und daraufhin haben Sie eine Pankratitis,
dann können Sie eine MRCP machen.
Ansonsten brauchen Sie eine CT bei Pankratitis,
das ist der Standard für Pankratitis.
Und natürlich, der Kollege hat richtig geschrieben,
das ist ein Parameter.
Wenn Sie eine Schul- und Durch-Litiasis haben,
dann haben Sie heute die Schul- und Stasawerte.
Da muss man an den Biliwerte schocken,
muss man dann AP, Gamma-Gethi,
weil die zeigen uns auch, wo den Weg hingeht,
was man im Vordergrund hat.
Wenn man heute AP, Gamma-Gethi und Bili hat,
dann ist es dann ja, zu sagen,
Folge von Gallengang.
Das könnte auch intrapathisch sein, das ist auch was anders,
weil das muss nicht extrapathisch, muss unbedingt sein.
Aber der Unterschied zwischen intrapathisch und extrapathisch,
dafür braucht man denn die MRCP zu unterscheiden,
ob der Probleme intrapathisch liegt und extrapathisch liegt.
Das ist ja nicht rein klinische Entscheidung,
sondern auch erlaborisch chemisch und diagnostik.
Weil Sie können nicht am Hanan am Nieser so sofort sagen,
das ist das schuleste Stitis.
Das könnte auch so ein Pankretitis sein,
könnte es schon nie ein Kollege sein.
Dann sagen Sie, ich würde meine Argumentation
oder meine verdachtige Gnosemittel,
Labo- und diagnostikverfahren oder Weltgebungverfahren abdecken.
Okay?
Ja, danke Ihnen.
Ich habe noch eine Frage im Sinne von...
Ich schulde mich, Leute.
Aber hier, man kann mit der Kurz-Abdomen verdacht
und im Vordergrund, pardon, verdacht auch kurz-Abdomen,
man braucht unbedingt eine CT, wenn man verdacht hat.
Das ist wieder ein chirurgisches Prozedur.
Wenn Sie so etwas haben im Notaufnahme
und Sie können es nicht unterschreiben,
von woher kommt denn die Kurz-Abdomen?
Die Kurz-Abdomen heißt nicht, dass es immer unklar ist.
Am meisten man kriegt das immer raus.
Wenn das unklar bleibt, dann braucht man unbedingt eine CT.
Man muss es dann chirurgisch vorstellen.